[Applause]
[Music]
okay before we get started with today's
video I've got to give you two warnings
the first is that we might have lewd
some spoilers about narcos obviously be
given that it's a TV show based on real
history I don't think this is so much of
a problem and the second warning is that
today we're going to talk about drug
trafficking a topic where the
information we have it's pretty
incomplete and all the time - Lisa
finding new bits of information that
could prove parts of this video wrong
so that being said let's move on to
Colombia the country that is known of
the country of a thousand rhythms the
country of coffee and the birthplace of
so many of those Latino singers they got
the whole world to dance nevertheless
what really made this country famous is
sadly this man Pablo immunised quadriga
video I simply wasn't there to keep
Westeros cool the king of cocaine the
man who basically created one of the
world's most dangerous industries at the
end of the 1980s Pablo Escobar or el
patron as his neighbors used to know him
controlled 90% of the worldwide
production of cocaine suddenly Marian a
city of 2 million inhabitants became the
Hollywood of cocaine however on December
the 1st 1993 he died during a shootout
with the police but you probably already
knew that so the question now becomes
well what happens after Pablo who took
his business and then there is the most
important question of all and that is is
there still cocaine trafficking in
Colombia well today we're certainly
going to answer all of those questions
but before we get into any of that let's
talk a little bit about cocaine
[Music]
after weed cocaine is the second most
consumed drug in the world but unlike
the first one cocaine is extremely hard
to find marijuana it grows anywhere on
the planet even in cold places like
North America grow houses are found all
the time and with just a little bit of
expenditure anyone can create at home
the optimal conditions for growing
cannabis but coca leaves they are a
different animal you need a very
specific habitat to grow them and this
is why only some countries can grow
these leaves the main countries are
Colombia Peru and Bolivia
[Applause]
in other words there is just space for a
few suppliers but on the other hand the
demand he won't stop growing and well
it's a global demands this is why
cocaine is such a high profit business
and this is why right after Pablo
Escobar's death there were lots of
people willing to take his place
Mafia Wars as you know Pablo Escobar was
the leader of the Medellin Cartel but
even before his death there was already
a second cocaine capital and that was
the city of Cali also in Colombia and
with a very similar population where
Pablo left a trail of bodies and chaos
ins wake Callie may problems disappear
with an army of lawyers and a mountain
of legal briefs
the meting cartel was Miami swimming
pools bikini girls tacky is a two-ton
Cadillac the Cali cartel was New York
elegant smooth subtle where they could
fuel the 24-hour nightlife with cocaine
and still make sure everybody showed up
for work on Wall Street the next morning
at first met Ian and Cali worked side by
side
but in Colombia when money's involved
blood and never bleep flows
the Cali cartel they wanted to take the
whole of Escobar's business but Betty
Nina had plenty of knockers who wanted
to do the same thing one of them was
Diego Fernandez Murillo aka Don Berna
[Music]
longer helps the police deal with Pablo
Escobar made an alliance with the Cali
cartel and even had close ties with a
right-wing paramilitary group called the
Colombian self-defense forces with Pablo
Escobar dead and buried Don Berna
started a new organization with this
paramilitary greed that the so called
oficina de Envigado at the same time
smaller narcos in medellin were also
fighting for their share the street you
see on the screen was the border between
one band and the other
[Music]
basically if you were a worker for the
oficina Envigado and crossed the street
someone would kill you immediately so as
you could imagine these were extremely
violent times for the city different
drug bands were killing each other
pretty much all the time meanwhile the
Cali cartel was way more subtle this is
Gilberto Rodriguez and his partner Pasha
Herrera they were high-class boys with
plenty of contacts among politicians and
judges in fact Gilberto Rodriguez paid
over 6 million dollars to finance the
campaign of one of the Colombian
presidents and estos Santha nonetheless
despite the influence in the corruption
after some time the inevitable happens
we are sworn go we are not any CLS
Castillo nationalization government has
started the extradition process from the
chief of the colleague cartel de Cali
nonetheless Don Berna violent as he was
had a totally different story among all
the characters that appear on the narcos
TV show Don Berna is the one who has
lasted the longest without being put
behind bars but wait just a minute
because now we can talk about the
characters that didn't appear on the
show at least in the first two seasons
and to prepare yourself because well
there's a lot to tell remember how Don
Berna was working with this right-wing
group well the political ideology was
more important than what you might think
for this group the Colombian
self-defense forces they were born to
fight against communist guerrillas in
the country
Revolutionary Armed Forces of Colombia
FARC fog it's more than just a simple
terrorist group in some areas of the
country they became a parallel
government more than an Alec I eat a
kind of thing they could be better
compared with - or Islamic state even
today a good part of the Colombian
rainforest is under the control of this
Marxist Leninist group FARC they have
their own doctors their own hospitals
and of course they collected their own
taxes say FEMA Carrie listen let's say
this group has over 20,000 members
spread across 24 of Colombia's 32
provinces as you can imagine FARC they
were not good friends of drug
trafficking yes drug traffickers and
terrorists they do have common enemies
but the idea of becoming a millionaire
by selling a product on the
international market doesn't sound very
Marxist besides extortion and kidnapping
they were pretty lucrative businesses as
well and FARC they were experts on these
matters add to this the fact that Don
Berna and his office Enid and Vigano who
had an anti-communist group on their
side and you can imagine of the war that
was about to happen only CPU they all
had yeah this is the boy aha
Municipality today it's covered by
plants and trees that is the north part
from where FARC launched rockets to the
other part of the municipality but well
business is business and the matter the
money fought could make with kidnapping
it was hard to resist the temptation of
drug trafficking so one day medina
caracas one of the main thought leaders
decided to try the cocaine business
[Music]
sixteenth front of the bark went from
200 members to over 800 due to cocaine
revenue which became one of the primary
waves the Korea's finance their
activities don't forget the fart had the
control of all the areas where coca
plantations were in fact they had
already extorted the growers nonetheless
with Medina Caracas as leader FARC
created their own fields and their own
distribution networks this it was all
happening by the year 2000 at this time
the Cali cartel it was already
dismantled but cocaine it was still
employing a good share of the Colombian
workforce
so well to summarize on the one hand we
have the oficina to n vanguard o with
dom burner as the leader and then we
have FARC on the other hand and between
these two there's also a plethora of
independent drug trafficking bands
called the back rim it was during this
time that Colombia chosen new President
Alvaro Uribe Uribe was born in Medellin
and his political goal was to end all
the violence and well this marked the
beginning of the
Huck's mafioso Alvaro Uribe was ready to
end the guerrilla warriors and the
right-wing groups at any cost this is
why in the year 2005 his defense
minister Camilo ospina signed a law that
is thought of with sadness in Colombia
this law was directive 0 to 9 and well
now you might be wondering well what's
so sad about that it sounds like it
could be a good thing this directive
said literally that the government would
give the equivalent of 19 hundred US
dollars to anyone who would murder agrea
fighter or a paramilitary right-wing
fighter
[Music]
basically if you were a soldier in the
Colombian Army and you wanted to have a
good career all you had to do was get
out and go on a manhunt and all of a
sudden well the death toll at FARC and
Monaco's it absolutely skyrocketed but
hollow a minute because this was just
the beginning finding FARC members it
wasn't an easy job but the reward given
by the Colombian government was really
really tempting this is why a lot of
soldiers started killing innocent
civilians after that they would dress
them in a FARC uniform and take a
picture of the dead body this was enough
to go to the government office and get
the money and this is something that
happens way more than once or twice
there is even a name for it in Colombia
the dead civilians were called false
positives and it became a major way for
people to make money in Colombia still
today the Colombian justice system has
over 3,000 ongoing cases of false
positives that need to be investigated
but wait a minute because while the
policies of President a rebate were
extremely controversial one thing has to
be set he made it way more complicated
for FARC guerrilla warriors raids on
cocaine fields and distribution networks
they became the norm and when your enemy
is killing dozens of your members you
are willing to sign an alliance with the
devil himself
some emails prove the links between the
FARC and the narco traffickers and one
of the messages amigo Conejo a guerilla
leader shows a clear connection with the
oficina the Envigado
as we said before folk were present at
all the plantations in some cases those
plantations they belong to the oficina
to Envigado more son belongs to the back
rim that we mentioned earlier on the
other hand some temptations were managed
directly by FARC these are where they
grew and processed coca leaves and turns
them into white powder then the big
cartel stepped in to distribute the
cocaine to other countries nonetheless
unlike the times of Pablo Escobar
Colombian cartels no longer have a
monopoly over distribution
[Music]
for instance when those Colombian narcos
want to send cocaine to the US they
partner with Mexican drug dealers when
they want to send it to Europe they work
with Italian Greek and Albanian Mathias
but we're gonna talk about all of that
in another video and not today the
important thing is despite drug
trafficking still being an issue today
meta-gene is now a peaceful City of
course there are still bad neighborhoods
where it's better not to walk through
especially on the outskirts of the city
but the city has made a big change
change for the better this pacts mafioso
has allowed all the players involved
with the cocaine business to make an
agreement so that each of them has their
territories and they have no reason to
kill each other yes cocaine is now
easier to find than ever but less people
die during the process
[Music]
[Applause]
so now you might be wondering well what
can happen now that FARC have made a
peace agreement with the Colombian
government well this could become an
opportunity for the back room to take
back control of the business that is now
in the gorillas hands but the truth is
those narcos they were also trying to
get a peace agreement with the
government that is just as profitable as
the one the FARC and negotiating crazy
as it sounds FARC claims to be a
political group with their ideology and
propaganda even available on their
website which can be visited by anyone
this is why they sit on equal terms with
the government however backroom are seen
as normal criminals with no politics or
ideology whatsoever and of course well
those narco is their thinking a why can
FARC talk with the governments and why
can't we the agreements between FARC and
the government they're extremely good
for the guerrillas and once again
everyone they want a piece of the cake
[Applause]
[Music]
but well that's a whole other story as
well and now it's your turn do you think
it's possible to end the trafficking of
cocaine or do you think it's simply a
matter that each time one band is
dismantled another one simply appears
well please do leave your answers in the
comment section below you should also
definitely visit the reconsider Media
podcast that they provided the voices on
this video that are not mine and don't
forget that we publish brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday so don't
forget to subscribe hit that button
below me now or you won't miss any post
also if you did like this video do give
us a thumbs up and as always I'll see
you in the next video and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear more
of my lovely voice don't forget to check
out the reconsider podcast at reconsider
Mediacom reconsiders a podcast that
challenges you to reconsider your views
by providing context but we don't do the
thinking for you